Alright,
think hard.
What is
circle
close spot,
definitely wrong.
Let's see,
I showed you two shapes,
sheep,
one in shape too,
and then I asked you would you be shapes
matches the word Boba and which matches
the word Kiki for 98 percent of people
shape one is Kiki and shaped to his Boba
and it doesn't matter if you're from
America,
India,
or your two and a half years old.
This result is extremely consistent
across all cultures and languages,
and so what does it mean?
I want to suggest that with this study
we can see how the brain gives abstract
meaning too many different shapes in a
consistent way,
and filmmakers use this phenomenon to
tell their story.
The best place to see this idea has to
be animation were animators can make
objects and characters from any shape
they want.
Let's start with the basics.
Circle,
square and triangle.
This may seem reductive,
but these shapes say a lot more than you
may think.
Evil characters are drawn like Kiki.
They have sharper features pointing
noses,
ears in long curly fingers,
and the lovable characters are designed
like Boba soft and round.
Is it a coincidence that the fluffiest
and least threatening character in
animation is named balloon?
To me,
this whole concept makes intuitive
sense.
Our brains are designed to c sharp and
pointy things is more threatening.
It just stood around on the top.
It needs to be pointed around.
It's not scary scary.
Notice how I can draw the nicest and
most recognizable character in animation
with three circles and notice how the
devil is commonly represented as a
collection of triangles,
but do it a little more subtly and
you're able to emit an emotional
response to the viewer without them even
noticing.
It happens during one of my favorite
movie moments of all time when we see
the wicked villain transformed from Kiki
into around vulnerable Boba.
You may think this only applies to
animation,
but is it a coincidence that darth
vader's mask has this shape and Lord
dark helmet?
The cartoonish and comedic parody of
Darth vader has this shape.
One of the sharpest villains is
maleficent,
and they even tried to keep her pointy
jaw line and eyebrows in the live action
remake.
Following these same principles,
what does it mean when you call somebody
a square?
It means they're boring.
Maybe they're old fashioned,
but a square can also symbolize
something that is sturdy and from sound
familiar.
Squares are rigid and slow to change if
the world is and how they want it to be.
Maybe they get a little angry.
If you really want to think abstractly,
the world of film exists inside a
rectangular shape.
A lot of important geometry comes from
framing.
The most significant framing to look for
is probably the frame within the frame.
This is used to show a character trapped
in their current situation.
Another less common,
but equally important frame with it.
The frame is the circle which gives the
geometric impression of surveillance and
spying
to go a step deeper than the frame
within the frame.
You can use lines to create a visual
jail cell in the frame,
whether it's through blinds in an office
or even a computer screen.
A collection of vertical and horizontal
lines can indicate a character is not
only trapped but held prisoner in their
current lifestyle.
These shots used geometry as a means of
visual storytelling as far back as I can
remember,
I always wanted to be a gangster and how
does even noticing it?
Framing is filled with lines.
Geometry is everywhere,
and the same principles apply.
Triangles can emphasize power dynamics.
Linear framing can show physical
separation.
We're straight lines can guide our
eyesight,
so the next time you rewatch your
favorite movie,
try analyzing the geometry of the
framing and characters.
If you do that,
then you're in good shape.
What's this one
couple of wavy lines.
Sorry.
This isn't your lucky day.
Thanks for watching.
Slightly.
Just a bit of a break from just a little
slot in the break.
The monotony of all that hardcore.
I want to think good blood for giving me
this idea in the first place with his
amazing crash bandicoot video.
I highly recommend it.